Shawn spices got a brand-new gig the
former White House press secretary is
going to be on Dancing with the Stars
GMA having some fun with it this morning
[Applause]
Shawn will be in charge of assessing
audience size Josie I asked Shawn about
this a year ago he would go on Dancing
with the Stars I said is a yes or no
question and he said the answer was no I
know how much is getting paid Oh would
you like me to tell you it's alright so
contestants make just for like the first
episode to get in 125 and then if you
keep advancing you get like 10 or 20
grand as you advance and then the final
contestant if you're there to like the
last pair 50 G's so if he can dance he
could be making north of 200,000 and
that's the only reason why anybody does
anything as much we have any Dancing
with the Stars fans at the table I used
to be used to fire aren't you they ran
out of real celebrities no offense
tracker it was no good nope
stop any of you stop me if it ever comes
to this for me do not do it do a reality
show fashion intervention
the only reality show I will do is like
without Greg it's a show where I'm paid
not to be in it that's the kind of
reality show okay no please I'm with you
you don't ever want to do dance with the
Stars saying no I just realize I would
rather do a thousand press briefings in
a row then have to do something again
where I'm out of my comfort zone like
when I did the celebrity jeopardy for
charity thing I've never been more
nervous in my life like crippling nerves
or nervous in a briefing absolutely 100
percent so I would know I would not be
it live but no one when they call you
well what are you gonna say
yeah I'll say you're gonna defeat racial
stereotypes no great dancer but I
noticed that this has now become an
argument a political argument because
people say that by having Spicer you're
politicizing this event and they didn't
want it to be politically I just wanted
to they want rating
and fun the left is the game political